hi guys so i just wanted to say hello
and this video is a special video
because it is a celebration video i
can't already tell that by the
background i just wanted to make a video
and say thank you guys for subscribing
because i finally hit the hundred
thousand subscriber mark this is uh
monumental i guess i think it is yes
it is monumental and to celebrate this
monumental occasion i'm gonna show you a
clip of me punching sexy phil in the
face if you didn't already see this on
his channel
whoa
thank you again to all of you
subscribers for subscribing and doing
what you do that's watching vids and
writing and commenting because i love
you so if you guys didn't already know i
do have a secondary youtube channel it's
youtube.com otheriijustine so don't
forget to go and subscribe there because
i post videos there daily i post behind
the scenes videos i post contest winners
and all kinds of other goodies that i
don't post here so if you're wondering
why i don't post more content well
actually i post it pretty much every day
so get over there youtube.com
and i'll see you guys at the 200 000
subscriber mark bye